there are many reasons of course there's
always it's not a one thing but I think
that look I I need to preface this
because it's important because the the
the short The Cliff Notes version is
they hate him because he wants men to be
better
and he has a positive message for men
but I don't believe that the answer for
men is to whine and complain
right so I'm not into like men's rights
movements because I just don't think
more than anything else I don't think
they're effective forget about how they
behave and the morality and whatever I
just I don't think people uh you know
we're biologically different and we're
programmed to have sympathy for women
and we're programmed to consider men
disposable uh that is the biologic
biological reality you're not going to
change it uh men creating movements
where they protest and complain about
the rights isn't going to change
anything uh men just have to be better
and work harder and uh you know look
after their own interests um and one of
the things about the interest of men is
is to find women who want to be with
them uh and who who don't hate men right
that's really how you you solve that
problem at an individual level but um
the reason that hey Jordan Peterson is
he came out and he unapologetically uh
wanted men to be better he wanted
everyone to be better and that's one of
the other reasons they didn't like him
of course but also he challenged the
ideology and the reason I say this
people will think I've been sort of
conspiratorial or whatever but if you if
you cast your mind back to like the
Kathy Newman interview and all of that
they all he did also an interview for GQ
with a woman called Helen Lewis who's
interviewed me and that they all all I
don't remember if she asked him this
specifically but lots of other
journalists all kept saying to him yeah
but the majority of the audience are men
what is that you know like like it was a
bad thing
no one goes to a Cosmetics company and
says the majority of the audience of
women why is that
because there's nothing wrong with women
but there's something wrong with men in
their world view uh and we you know we
hear it in the language of wokeness you
know you're just a straight white man
you're a toxic toxic masculinity or
toxic this toxic that and I think the
reason that Jordan Peterson came under
attack is because not only uh was he
trying to tell men and women but
particularly meant to be better he also
embodied traditional masculine virtues
that people don't want to see men
exhibit in the world
what do you think like the one or two
top uh masculine attributes are that
people don't want to see
confidence strength someone who is not
going to back down someone is gonna you
know fight his corner all the way again
people because people are stupid I have
to say this is I'm not saying women
can't be strong and confident right but
but we don't like to see Men Express
those things if you look at movies if
you look at television shows if you look
at stand-up the guy is always the Goof
the idiot the this the that it's weak
pathetic and the woman is the the girl
boss and whatever that's what apparently
we these people want to see
um so the they didn't want to see a guy
who would come along and go actually no
you're wrong about that and I'm gonna
I'm gonna make the argument and I'm
gonna argue the case and I'm gonna
persuade you and if you don't agree with
me well you're wrong like they don't
want to see that they wanna they wanna
attack him and then for him to back down
yeah it is interesting that you
mentioned movies I think there's been a
very very big difference between uh even
people who are cast uh for certain uh
roles uh but the story lines of many of
these movies right you start to see I
always joke like the movie version of
the mannequins inside of the store where
they used to be uh would essentially
look like ripped you know models and now
they've got dad bods and uh that's
celebrated to a degree you also are
starting to see some of that in movies
um where the you know hero or whatever
uh actually doesn't look or act the same
way that they would have 10 15 20 years
ago uh definitely not 50 years ago and I
do wonder how much of that uh is
programming children's mind who then
will grow to be adults uh and has a
long-term Impact versus nah they watch a
movie and then they go and they see you
know a sports star on television where
it can't be faked like you you can't be
fat and be in the NBA right for the most
part like you you have to be an athletic
person who is able to uh actually
accomplish the task uh I I know what you
mean look uh we I mean the media the
Hollywood the powerful machines for
communicating stereotypes to people
right that's that's what it's about and
if all you see uh when you're growing up
is men who are weak and pathetic then
people are going to take that message to
heart now of course some people will
rebel against that
um but My worry is not only that it's
also like uh and I talk about it this in
my sub stack about Jordan why the hey
Jordan Peterson is like I don't know if
you've noticed this
but there's been an explosion in people
going to the gym specifically to look
buff not to like be healthy or whatever
but to like look buff like it's it's a
look thing for a lot of people and and
my view on it is and again it's
something I just it's a theory I'm not
saying this is necessarily true but it's
the one area where men are still allow
it to express authentic masculinity like
you are allowed to go to the gym and
lift weights that's not toxic not yet
there will be a time when that becomes
toxic as well uh right and they they're
already articles about how going to the
gym and being healthy is right wing like
they're already writing them
um but but it's it's the one area where
men can go and be men and show up in the
world as men and I think that's why it's
kind of displaced masculinity and that
worries me to some extent don't get me
wrong the gym is healthy Jim's gray
exercise gray lifting's great all of
that stuff is great but some people now
think that to be a man is to look like a
man and that is not what to be being a
man is about at all being a man is about
how you carry yourself in the world what
kind of father you are what kind of
husband you are what impact you have on
the world what kind of leader you are
these are the things that make a man a
man uh you don't uh you don't have to be
I'm not saying it's bad I'm just saying
you know that can't be the only place
that men Channel their energy to be
masculine like that energy that people
spend going to the gym you might want to
spread that around a bit in terms of
some other things that's all I'm saying
the last thing I want to talk to you
about uh is Bitcoin and actually we
haven't talked about this so I have no
clue if you know anything about Bitcoin
if you're interested in it at all but a
lot of I think your view of the world